Cinderella every little girl's dream
come true after six films of not having
a continuing story run all the way
through this was finally a return to the
three act structure Cinderella the
famous fairy tale tells the story of a
young woman who's been turned to a maid
by her stepmother and her evil
stepsisters her bunch of animal friends
help her out of course and try to keep
things jolly but when the night of the
ball approaches and she isn't able to go
her fairy godmother appears and gives
her a dress and carriage to make it out
there I guess by this point it was
trying to return to the roots of Snow
White you got the pretty damsel you have
the animal sidekicks they have a softer
more realistic human being as the main
star as opposed to a company animal and
of course you have the evil terrifying
villains
I guess Cinderella is one of those it
gets hard done a lot from being very
anti feminist just wait around wish and
your dreams will come true
first of all ten Pinocchio start that
and second I don't know from a male
point of view growing up I never thought
she was that bad I always saw a lot of
patience with her I mean yeah I guess
you never really did anything but at the
same time the fact that she was willing
to put up with so much and yet still
find some happiness in her everyday life
there's got to be some really good
values in there as a character there
isn't really too much else to her but to
be honest the virtues I listed before I
think those are enough the villain is
great I love that by simply having
control over one person's life this can
be one of the great Disney baddies the
way she's animated the way she stares
the way she smiles she's a great one the
songs of course everybody knows
bibbidi-bobbidi-boo and so forth and the
animation is sort of a nice return to
those softer colors they were made
popular it Snow White and Fantasia one
of my main problems again though is the
prints God does he even get a line in
this movie his dad actually has more
dialogue in fact the movie is much more
about the dad wanting him to fall in
love than him actually wanting to fall
in love maybe taking an angle from the
princes point view might have been more
interesting but maybe if you did you'd
see just how really twisted and kind of
sick this story is hey he found a woman
strictly based on sight
hey he knew her for a few hours and he
decided she's the one Hey all she left
is a shoe and yet somehow that's going
to determine which woman you're going to
marry Hey
coincidentally the shoe size can only
fit one friggin woman in the entire
world and thank God it just happened to
be the one you fell in love with yeah I
guess that is a little screwy as the
Disney films go especially the ones that
are used the traditional princessy
formula this one's okay it's got some
really good moments and really good song
sequences and like I said a really cool
villain but a lot of it also seems like
filler just the animals are walking
around being goofy having fun when
really you could have been spending that
time developing some of the other
characters like oh I don't know again
fell for a game Prince but the artwork
is pretty impressive too watching it
again I really like the scale that they
give a lot of these houses and castles
they actually do make it seem rather
massive and this is before white screen
it's the basic return to the classic
fairy tale and it does it pretty
decently and any problems it does have
story wise I think you can attribute to
just the time period and well the fact
that it is a fairy tale
well often we're just sort of written
this way I think it holds up okay one of
my personal favorites but it's
definitely pretty good
you